British restaurants were once a
laughting stock not anymore today we
have some of the most exciting
restaurants in the world together with
the best restaurant team I've chosen the
best and tonight my two favorite
restaurants will be going head-to-head
they may be good but do they have what
it takes to go right to the
[Music]
top over the past 6 months my team and I
have been all over the country checking
out your best restaurant nominations and
tonight my competition continues this
time to find the best North
African North African food is like no
other the careful layering of different
spices results in wonderfully aromatic
dishes one mouthful can really transport
you to a completely different
world the best restaurants will mix
gutsy flavors with Rich sweet and
intricate combinations of spices to
deliver dishes that will excite all the
senses I'm hoping tonight's contenders
will show what this fantastic Cuisine
has to
offer tonight my two favorite North
African restur restaurants will battle
it out for a place in the
semi-finals from Central London it's
Momo a glamorous celebrity haunt as
renowned for its vibrant atmosphere as
its food got one more M table two we've
got a great team and a great feeling and
great passion and we we're going to win
it the moment machine is taking on Azo
from Hammer Smith West London a small
family run restaurant loved by the
locals yes I think I am the best I would
love to see someone challenging me a
furious fight as two London restaurants
take each other on in three
extraordinary
challenges the first is every
restaurant's worst nightmare 30 hungry
diners who will arrive and order all at
the same
time first they're heading for Momo
tucked away behind London's region
street it's run by a very passionate
northerner Dave he's been cooking since
the age of 15 and he now heads up a
brigade of 26 chefs this R has also been
visited by some serious aist from
Madonna to gwenth palro and if they can
look after those kind of customers my
diners today are in for a real
treat hey David how are you very well
thank you how are you very good very
good so the six success of momo has been
what we all work together as a team and
we create we created an atmosphere and
hopefully delicious food yeah open 13
years ago it's excellent food stylish
surroundings and party atmosphere
quickly established Momo as one of
London's most fashionable
[Music]
restaurants
as soon as you enter it's like a theater
you come in you see the atmosphere you
see The Deco you see the buzz you want
to get involved we get lots of film
stars lots of footballers politicians
lots of you know people want to go
through the back door what I love most
about Momo is you feel comfortable
straight away and the atmosphere is it's
quite sexy I need one lamp taji no
corander three miniature 37y old David
has cooked in kitchens all over the
world cooking has been my life from from
the age of 14 and a half 15 50 a away
table 50 Tajin lamb solid steak medium
rare yes during his travels in Morocco
David Fell in Love with North African
food I love the passion of Moroccan
Cuisine I think it's a great flavors
everybody thinks Moroccan Cuisine is
cuscus and Tajin it's vast assisted for
seven years by French susf Philip David
gives traditional recipes his own
personal touch doesn't look like a crem
boule that's delicious only a yorksh
would [__] fryer Creme Brule but it
works David that's some of the best food
I've tasted so far in this competition
make sure that you give my diners the
exact experience you've just delivered
to
me now Momo is about to be put through
its Paces because my Rous diners have
arrived all expecting food and service
fit for London's Literati hello welcome
Ino and the service shouldn't pose a
problem as front of house manager Morad
has a team of nine waiters this place
deals with big numbers easily so they
can become a little bit complacent
because there's only 30 diners coming in
and sometimes rans get bad reputations
for just looking after the the a-listers
and forgetting the real customers so
first ticket on you order one scallop
one m zuk one fish the day two M
Medium as first orders arrive headchef
David directs his Brigade like a
conductor with an orchestra don't start
14 don't start six year please don't put
all nine past here at the same time
please don't more crispy that past here
2 minutes past here make sure the first
three or four tables go fast and slow
down there are three starters Moroccan
Obin caviar with mixed Peppers wood pin
pasta a delicate North African pie and
scolars with obene Chutney and a fresh
herb
salsa David's on fire and the first
starters are out within minutes any
problems anywhere any just we're really
sort of rush rushed yeah really rush and
it looks like we're about to get our
main course already damn okay well let's
hope the main don't come out as far as
it would be nice to relax a bit
it's the two ladies on the end here
don't throw their main course out as
quick you know hold it back a little bit
David is doing his best to control the
flow of food send table one and slow
down on 14 and six but it's front of
house who need to pay service and make
sure every table gets their food at the
right time I've just told the team to
slow down slow down it's not a
race very good flavor combination light
cooked incredibly well yeah very tasty
absolutely delicious some of my diners
are less impressed gentlemen the pigeon
pasta how's that it's okay it's a bit
too dry and um not enough pigeon damn
and what was wrong with the pigeon it
was just a bit too dry and just oh I
didn't like it can you put one in for me
okay the pigeon pasty is really
authentic you got three layers you've
got like a onion compost pigeon and like
scrambled eggs and top with almonds it's
not dry if anything it needs a bit more
pigeon in
there
for Mains there's a choice of three
smoked lamb shank with cuscus and spicy
sausages fish wrapped in Vine leaves
with white beans and that North African
staple chicken
Tajin have the chicken Tajin Tajin you
know Terra dish of course a very
traditional I love the way you taste
every tajine that's going out he may be
doing it every day but you're still
tasting it every
time the kitchen is focused while front
of house look busy but don't seem
coordinated David you have is a little
bit impatient with the starters how long
waiting not long there are lots of
waiters but it doesn't seem like the
managers are controlling service and
some of my diners have slipped through
the net um STS obviously haven't arrived
yet no everyone else is getting their
main courses so just wondering what's
going on cuz they're kind of hungry how
long you waiting about 25 25 minutes
yeah that's that's too
long how that big table of six there
with the starters what's go Table Six
coming in about 3 minutes 3 minutes just
SL down so we not get everything way at
the same time yes finding that balance
one table complain is too fast one table
complain is too slow so you got to just
try to find that balance to who hasn't
had their main courses you know when you
get 30 customers at once you want to
serve it like a party it's very hard to
pace yourself one thing they're not is
short staffed they seem to have a
manager for teaspoons a manager for the
bread a manager for the lid the cuscus
so servers should be impecable today so
they should get that balance right you
can't serve a table two courses with one
table nothing that's bad man man agement
and far too many chiefs in the dining
room and not enough Indians in fact
there's more managers in this dining
room there are grains of [__]
cuscus we definitely come again we said
that as soon as the main course came out
actually that it's it's a lovely feeling
here we've been made to feel very
comfortable it did take quite a while to
come in to receive my food I didn't like
waiting that long to to be honest but
what we got was nice lunch is over but
I'm disappointed that service was
inconsistent for some of my diners
timing was all over the shop and that
was down to the the suited and booted
the managers far too many managers and
um a real lack of communication with the
kitchen and thank God David was on fire
because we had too many managers on the
floor that couldn't spot who been served
what okay big test that one you're used
to big numbers so 30 diners should have
been a walk in the park how' I go for
you went very well I really enjoyed it
very well nice Buzz a great Buzz great
atmosphere yeah great atmosphere my
biggest concern today was the fact that
there was one table next to the big
table that had their start as the main
courses and the six stop had nothing to
eat when somebody hasn't got food in
front of them and they're eyeing up the
table next door to them they get jealous
we had two complaints the py for the
pigeon if anything maybe not so small in
terms of dice so they can identify what
they've got on the fork as a piece of
pigeon and you didn't sell enough
desserts I thought that was the best
crem bruy I've ever tasted in a decade
share the starter but make sure you save
room for that dessert that's how good
they are well done
EXC it's nice to have feedback and even
if it's negative or not good feedback it
keeps you on your toes
dancing we've got a great team and a
great feeling and great passion and we
we're going to win it we're here to
win service please t 10 next other North
African Contender AO creates magical
dishes from a kitchen lost in time he
hasn't got a nonstick [__] pan for
God's sake you know those pans are all
than me and that's saying
something it's the North African heat of
my Nationwide restaurant competition and
30 hungry diners are about to descend on
my second competitor here in Hammer
Smith is one of the best kept secrets in
town this is a zoo a romantic small
North AF restaurant run by a lovely
husband and wife team Chris and Chris
now although it's small it's punching
way above his weight a serious Contender
to go all the way in this
competition hello Chris good and good to
see youwise we good to see you too look
how small this place is chis hello this
kitchen is a size of a cupboard look at
it it is it is thank God you're small
and thin and good
looking unbelievable they're scary what
are they on there for let's the take
away I'll take away
okay former head mistress Chris and her
Chef husband Chris open a zoo 11 years
ago they work 7 days a week running this
35 cover restaurant with the help of
just five other members of Staff I've
got Constantin R man cuscus two large
plates please we give our all to this
restaurant I do love working hard I mean
you manage once a century to have sort
of day off where you want to stand by
but you feel like guilty why am I away
and and that guil makes your day not a
day off you cook every day and it's it's
a passion it's never a job for you is it
yes it is what's the secret behind the
success of your food my wife your wife
Chris I don't know what to do without
her to be honest she's very very good
support and believes really in what I do
for that I love you more thank you Chris
learned to cook authentic North African
food at his grandmother's knee in
Algeria this is the food of my childhood
when I was living in Algeria when she
was cooking uh she's always you know
having you next to her and you see how
you do she's doing it and it looks like
he's still cooking with her pots too
when was the last time you bought a new
pan that's a good question what have you
changed in 10 years in this kitchen uh
not much where's the fridge I've got
this one here ah okay right wow okay
great sardines and
hmer they're delicious M iy very rare
you see sardines today everyone thinks
it's a oily fish and no one wants it but
that is delicious wow there's very few
chefs that I know with a michan star
that can cook like he can I'm very
passionate about my food I mean it makes
me
happy Chris is such a perfectionist he
insists on overseeing everything that's
cooked in his Tiny Kitchen sorry for
taking over no worries Grace like even
he wants to check everything from the
scratch even I think I work with him 20
years he going to never is going to
change I do strive to be the best K I
will carry on doing it
until till the end because this is it
this is my
life and his life is about to be turned
upside down by my next
[Music]
challenge okay my Diner is going to be
here in just under 5 minutes yeah I'm
going to be watching everything I'll be
in the kitchen watching how you work and
I'll be in the dining room scrutinizing
everything your reputation is legendary
tonight it's on the line Chris has just
2 hours to cook and serve two courses
for 30 customers quite a pressure for a
small restaurant and the clock starts
now hello
hello hope you enjoy your evening with
us thank you thank
you three fish t one lamb c c fish yeah
yeah it's quickly become clear that it's
not just the kitchen that's stuck in a
Time Warp Chris so when you take the
orders there's no computers it's all
handwritten chicks and you much prefer
that as opposed to the 21st century well
it works if it works don't change it mhm
uh what am I
doing in a fluster Chris has put the
wrong table number on an order and now a
second order has come in for the same
table table four can you remember what
he
did hold it hold it hold it hold it how
long first error of the evening that
that's done twice don't worry thank you
do you prefer this by handwritten like
that is it easy for you I got used to it
but if they two tables of four is
confusing right yes it is if you had a
cter you wouldn't have these problems
yeah no that was my fault I should have
have done it yeah he's your husband yes
I know he's your head chef he's your toy
boy look after
him there is a choice of three starters
marinated sardines with spicy sauce
grilled pepper salad with merg sausages
no LA and a brick a Tunisian specialty
pastry filled with tuna potato and a
soft egg then deep fried Chris wa these
have been here for 2 minutes the egg
yolk is running and I want them to
experience their dying what table number
table 15 service please Jesus you're in
the you're welcome so the secret when
you cut in that egg yolk should sort of
run all over the tuna there it is wow
yeah really really good not too spicy
not too sweet really well
balanced okay with the starters over
Chris has 30 complex Mains to cook on
his tiny stove there are three choices
of Tajin go go go go go go go go go go
cod with King prawns and seafood chicken
with olives and preserved lemons or lamb
in a spicy sauce handed down from his
grandmother I'm ready although he's got
a sous chef and two others to help him
just as I thought perfectionist Chris
wants to do everything himself okay
thank you I'll do that don't worry if he
carries on like this food will be
delayed I need two cuscus two cus two
cuscus why don't you do the
cuscus the cuscus yeah but he's doing
everything three fish fish what's he
doing on your section now it's dressing
the plat sorry can't you dress the plat
you've got the one working there pans
everywhere one two three of you do
nothing yeah is the chef he doesn't want
to
say okay Al
Al it's the only way I can watch you
cook where yeah where through the bars
there's more space out here there is in
there you've got to take some of the
responsibility away from him oh come
on incredible I mean I thought I was a
control freak Chris takes it to a
completely different level and he just
cannot delegate you're a control freak
well I'm not a control freak but but
you're doing everything no well no well
I just want him to open up and talk the
danger one person fish finger Bowl
including oh [__] me I'm sure you can
get your own finger Bowl um do you need
them to get you a finger
Bowl you do yeah one finger Bowl please
for the fish tajine this is ridiculous
front of house should be helping the
kitchen not hindering finger ball oh
jeez it it's potentially C A because
he's so used to that onean band top of
the tube station again you have the
drums the guitar the organ in the mouth
and he's just playing everything and
everyone's running around him
crazy now he pushes him off his bench
and goes in there chops the peppers and
he's got about 12 things going on the
stove I mean the gu's a freak you you
can see him can't you organizing his own
fun jumping in the coffing and saying
goodbye to everyone saying the prayer at
the End closing the lid Messi
AV ball thank you very much finger ball
thank you don't bother catching for
nothing excellent coming up to halfway
there and he won't offload to go in and
tell him to do something else he's got
his concentration I think we need to
keep his but why is he paying all those
members of staff and he's doing
everything on his shoulders Chris not
setting his Brigade near the stove means
some customers are still waiting for the
mains it's been a while now yeah 25
minutes i' say this guy won't accept
help from anyone I've got to get through
to him somehow can you start talking to
your Brigade oh wait okay guys hello how
are you come on come on let's go Ali
let's get on with it I've got the fish
you've got
everything
Chris last table look at me for 2
seconds is there any chance so give them
that you can stand over here and let
your Sue Chef your second chef and your
third Chef cook the last table go
outside and take some fresh air just out
there just just to 2 minutes you come
over here and you go and get some fresh
air out
out right let them do it okay just the
last table I kill you guys if you don't
do it properly you're going to be dead
in 2 weeks if you continue like this let
it
go okay last table how long uh LZ 3
minutes come on
guys give one more leave him alone H
he's
fine that's something I have to work on
but you know when you love cooking
that's what you
do
fish delicious really really good very
tender very Sav
mint really comes through full of flavor
little bit of spice really nice the food
is wonderful the place has got so much
charm so much character such a great
welcome we full at home here it's a
family run place and we love it really
good service is over and my diners are
leaving
happy okay right first of all service
unique ladies well done thank you yeah
even down to the handwritten tickets
okay the first ticket went in second
ticket two tables of doesn't matter and
as for the
kitchen oh where do I start with you
food is delicious Sublime just amazing
my biggest problem is you I want
thousands more of customers to enjoy
your food but you won't be around if you
don't open up and delegate me I will
you'll be surprised on what it does
messy well done ser well done really
good thank
you good job good J well done Chef well
done well done Chef well done what was
good for me is realizing that I I must
delegate you take it on board yeah put
it this way I will take more break
[Music]
M guy's a genius he cooks like an angel
he hasn't got all the pictures fittings
and the posher dress but what he has got
is an amazing pallette and for me
somebody to watch very
closely for AO and Momo my coach trip
was like being hit by a hurricane
however they both came through and
they're still standing strong now I've
invited to my office to meet
up with the help of secret diners I've
uncovered how these restaurants perform
when they think I'm not
around I sent top food critic Simon
Davis to Momo Undercover hoping they'd
improved on their service
[Music]
problems after I left
Momo I sent in my secret
diners and they filmed your restaurant
undercover
okay this is what happened hi there I'm
how are you very good thank cuz what's
your name Duncan Duncan we need to be
out of here in about an hour and a half
or something um sorry my English is
English not just I call your English is
good bit better a little bit better it's
good let's go for the wood pigeon and
the prawns and then we'll have I think a
tajid so we've seen two of the waiters
now are you ready for the man
course sorry are you ready for the man
course I wanton at the same time no I
mean are you ready to order the man
we've ordered already oh you ready order
sry yeah we're
good some times we get overwhelmed and
we just like help each other um but of
course obviously here lack of
communication yeah but if somebody's in
a rush that gets set across the board to
everybody doesn't it in turns
off
P here I don't think it looks wildly
appetizing it looks a little bit
dry the wood pigeon be minced to such a
degree you can't really distinguish it
from any other me in my opinion I think
mincing up the wood Pig is is an
[Music]
error they didn't they didn't mince out
that little piece of wood pigeon
shouldn't leave bones in it annoying
it's also bloody
dangerous
bone yeah it's one of the things where
clumsy yeah but to to be honest with you
it does happen ever so often but it's
just yeah care and attention can I have
a little side order of tabuli tabuli
yeah just a little a little bit of
tabuli and we it was almost as if he was
too busy to to deal with us oh no I
wanted I've got some of that is that
some no I I wanted a little bowl of
taboi yeah but it is a bit perplexing
we've had two occasions now where
they've been in a mistake cuz they're
not communicating with each other excuse
me I ordered some tabuli I wondered if
it was coming to be to be honest with
you I'm now confused about what I've
told which
waiter as my tab thank you so the Tabo
is arrived but it was a good 10 minutes
and I had to ask two different waiters
and it got delivered by a third
fragmented Service as opposed to two
waiters looking after that they've been
interrupted four or five times with five
different waiters it's a a busy
restaurant and you know you've got to
nobes took control there no
excuse they haven't filled our water up
since we
arrived I'm just going to leave that
there it's in a very prominent position
we'll just see if they fill it up should
I have a little more
water it's over an hour since I had any
water and now I've asked for some and it
still hasn't come excuse
me have some
water ah the water just cuz it's the
Moroccan restaurant doesn't mean we have
the water retention ability of a camel
sly oh we've been waiting an hour for
water they shouldn't be waiting that
long for water definitely not I mean for
me to watch that it's very you know um
yeah disappointed he's met so many
waiters and none of them noticed that
the the the water glass they were empty
but you are somewhat overstaffed with
bodies there when you've had the eighth
the ninth the 10th waiter hit the table
you feel a bit sort of Jesus we I'm just
you know on a converb out here and just
been passed along to the next person as
a restaurant that
transport you to another place you can
eat good food perfectly good food you
can have fun here and if going out and
eating out in restaurants is about
having fun and excitement and sharing
that with your friends then this takes a
lot of boxes the food's good bloody good
a few areas of tightening up service
needs to come together glamorous great
attentive individuals but they need to
play as a team and then when the team's
all singing off that Hy sheet you've got
one amazing restaurant
[Music]
it's good to get construed CIS we go
back and we sort it out that's what we
get paid for sometimes H us to hurts the
most but you just get back up again more
stronger hello next my secret Diner
tests the flexibility and patience of AO
it's actually just too spicy for me I'll
give you another one but I charge you
for this
one wrong and both r meet to battle it
out in my kitchen I want to show the
next level the next Dimension North
African food it is the best T in if you
want it you come to
me it's the North African heat in my
best restaurant competition and Charming
family Runner Zoo from West London are
going head-to-head with Central London
slly giant
Momo don't start 14 don't start six year
please leave him alone H he's fine
now it's the turn of AO to hear some
difficult home through thanks to my
undercover secret
diner food and recipe writer Sarah Duran
Robertson has traveled in North Africa
and sampled the cuisine
firsthand AO will have to be on top form
to impress
[Music]
her what I'd like to tell you is that
you've actually been tested twice have
we that's a news my undercover team
right went to your restaurant mhm oh
gosh and this is what happened
hello table for two Duncan yes please
thank
you maybe and well maybe the sardines
and the olives I
think thank
you
hi do you know
what could I two of those and it must be
ready already now sorry it must be
cooked now oh could I have the prawns
though instead and the
borak I don't know if the chef will ask
the chef I
don't okay if you could
ask okay if the customer changes their
mind that's their prerogative because
they're paying right and we have to show
that level of
flexibility said it's already done it's
what's already
done she's already gosh that was very
quick okay well could I still do you
mind if I still
change change what so I'd like to not
have the sardines what sardines is
already now okay but could I order
something else as an extra order then
could I just have the Bor yes rule
number one never humiliate a customer
yeah and already she's been made to feel
vulnerable awkward and very silly all
because she just wanted to change her
dish hello yes I'm sorry this is just a
bit too spicy for me that is the in the
menu it's spicy hot yes I know I know
and he did say yes but I thought it's
actually just too spicy for me I'll give
you another one but I charge you for
this one okay that's no problem
yeah mhm wrong when customers arrive in
restant for the very first time and they
make a mistake on their order we have to
be prepared to change you want the
customers to come back
right Watch What Happens Next this one
has staway maybe he can have it tomorrow
or something a that's really kind thank
you yes cuz I've hardly touched it
you're very good yeah thank
you thank you
you
no that's incredibly quick how did he do
that well you you have to do it with him
eating the same time so I just had to
speed the
process thank you thank you so much
pleasure this is absolutely
delicious I have been to mares some of
the best food have ever
had and this takes me right
back so you pulled it back in a very
Charming way see and look at the
difference in what happened when we
changed that dish amazing I love this
place Chris is amazing so Charming your
customers are in love with you and your
food okay and if you want to charge them
ring me up and I'll pay for the [__]
dish okay
okay I've got a good team I trust my
team I believe in my team
and that did happen it won't happen
again and that's it now is let's see
what's coming
ahead and Momo I found my test really
tough but honestly I do admire their
fighting Spirit now it's time for the
final challenge as both teams cross
London to come and cook in my Flagship
restaurant and this is the very last
chance they've got to
shine the test is to create one
mindblown dish worthy of my Michin St
restaurant I want them to really push
themselves and cook like they've never
done
before only one restaurant can go
through to the
semi-finals this is what dreams are made
of a farmer's boy I mean I've I was a
butcher so this is this is you know to
make them proud as well I want to win I
really want to win being in Ramsey's
restaurant it's an honor and I'm very
very happy I think um I'm not going to
disappoint in tonight it is very very
important
day
welcome welcome good to see you right
you're in this competition because both
your restaurants are
unique the excitement behind the North
African cuisine and what it can deliver
in textures flavors spice is
mind-blowing this is the dish of your
life right because this is what's going
to catapult one of you into the
semi-final make sure it's
you good
luck I've asked them to come up with one
Exquisite dish featuring lamb a star
ingredient of North African
cuisine one side with Theo you've got
traditional and on the other side with
Momo you got this new wave a light style
of North African cuisine and completely
opposite ends of the spectrum to help me
choose who's best both teams Creations
will be served to highly distinguished
guests including Elsie auu director of
the royal African society lvi Riki head
of culture and press at the Moroccan
Embassy and distinguished Moroccan chef
and restaurant Joseph belti the front of
house teams from both restaurants are
also dining here today David is an
excellent Chef I know everything's going
to be delicious it's like a holiday
cooking for 20 I'm usually cooking for
200 so should technically be a walk in
the park it's an enormous challenge but
I think he will coope very well sugar
ham Where is the hamis going to have a
tree I mean for God's sake my one big
concern today with AO is he's been so
used to cooking his little Bol hole it's
a completely different set today I hope
doesn't get the better of him and he
just stays focused now you a little bit
lost in the kitchen with all the space
or you happy with something so big I'm
fine you'll be fine
excellent Chris is cooking a traditional
spicy lambene so with cuscus but he's
not stopping there I asked you to cook a
stunning lamb dish you've done that
extra mile and you're making bread right
the authentic semolina bread will be
sered with fresh hamus a unique [__]
mixture of tomatoes roasted Peppers
chilies and
coriander drink up a table four lamb
tajine yes sir Momo four stunning lamb
yes sir thank
you David from Momo is preparing a
delicious roast loin of lamb with obene
Ragu barley couscous and a lamb's liver
with Hara wrapped in spinach and deep
fried in tampura batter I want to do
something else in North African food I
want to show the next level the next
Dimension we can go L's Li Tempur and
you're wrapping the liver in yeah some
spinach wrapping spinach de fry it
hopefully it's about 50 51 seconds yeah
we time it last time Christ so you
really are pushing the boat out in a big
way this incredible he's pushing the
boundary out with the Lamb's liver which
is not everyone's cup of tea I just hope
in hour time that doesn't come back to
bite him on the ass
give me an estimated time for for a 5
minutes max Chef if there's ever a night
to work as a team this is it but as the
pressure builds Chris is up to his old
tricks not just make it ready for me
I'll show you first no he he's such a
control freak wait wait I check he can't
stop and he can't help himself he wants
to do
everything no no no no you don't touch
the plates yeah okay as us first dishes
hit the pass within minutes Jesus go
that was quick okay service please first
table coming now Rob let's go ASO Chef
full cover Table
Six pass Chris yes chef it's dinner yeah
take your time yes problem Chef please
let's go Chris is cooking faster than
[__] us say bolt runs he's just
totally fuckus refuses to talk to me and
his head is steeped right in that
couscous and Forin here we are thank
you let's go
[Music]
amazing really the bread is bread is
like I remember my
grandmother that's happened tastes too
amazing yeah I'm very proud of him the
sauce was too much sauce for me ready
for my test drown
yeah Chef David's modern take on North
African cuisine is a lot more
sophisticated s up Che yeah good the
five elements to his disc F requireed
delicate timing and suf philli is
getting ahead of himself Chef don't
slice too soon not ready no ready Chef
not ready don't go yeah I'll give you 90
seconds before I want the LA come on
listen to David Philip slow down please
don't SCE that lamb too early yes sir
yeah when David gives you the call yeah
on that juice yeah in amongst that
couscous not left on the board yes
please and you know Philip you can leave
it resting here leave it fat side down
like that and all he's going to do is
render and stay nice and warm see what
I'm saying thank you yeah yes slow that
one down Chef yeah Chef slow that one
down yes at this stage in the
competition David can't afford to make
mistakes Philip yeah one more or one's
not good two more org I'm waiting to get
every dish perfect Momo need to pull
together as a team cus yes go pH get my
hand dressing as well please yes yes
yeah like a proper teamwork good in the
middle so you can work off both tray
there you go put the Lamb on yes ah [__]
and they've pulled it off David they
look fantastic very nice are beautiful
colors okay service please TR up
please table two please
yes fantastically onate looking food
see very nice it's just that musty
Smokey feel it's something a bit
different we kind of all agreed that
liver is not our favorite thing on the
list but the way executed it was
excellent it melts in your
mouth the flavors aren't quite as
complex little bit of a cook it's a bit
dry it is yes the last of Chris's
Exquisite Tajin are flying out of the
kitchen C here's just one table to serve
here we are next Chef that smells
amazing delicious that was fast was good
next yeah breathe take some fresh
air last T DAV
you lovely well done let well done well
done service is over and it's time to
find out what my distinguished guests
think about these two extraordinary
dishes starting with
AO right how was your lamb shank the
lamb shank was my favorite as soon as I
experienced that sauce I knew that was
it yeah authentic and delicious I just
enjoyed it for what it was very simple
perfectly Blended I dipped the bread in
first mouthful oh I like them both but I
thought the the Momo dish was fresh it
was beautifully presented it was just
all together delightful I prefer the AO
dish you could just imagine yourself
being in the old so definitely I
preferred them inan Momo dish because
the meat was very well cooked I'm used
to Moroccan Cuisine because I'm moroccon
myself so it is really a sort of no
Cuisine the Templar reliver I was not
expecting it to be quite as mouth
wateringly sort of melt on the tongue as
it was it was really really delicious I
love the AO dish I adore the flavors
they were so powerful I wanted
more my Diner's comments confirm the
Brilliance of the food served here by
both AO and Momo I think the dish went
extremely well I tasted it I'm very
happy with it I'm happy but you know
there's always room for improvement but
what made me proud is we've come
together I'm really proud thank you Chef
both these teams of amazing chefs have
approached North African cuisine in very
different ways let's see if the
traditional is going to be uh modern
let's hope the traditional
is now I have an incredibly difficult
decision to make because only one
restaurant can go through to the
[Music]
semi-finals my two top North African
contenders Momo and AO both from London
have thrown everything at the final
challenge they are both outstanding
restaurants but over the course of my
three tests they've both made mist
mistakes I'm about to tell one of them
they've cooked in this competition for
the last
time to help me make my choice I need to
taste both dishes starting with David's
from Momo it looks modern 21st century
and stunning very pretty almost too
pretty for North African
cuisine Lamb's delicious I mean really
delicious delicate cooked beautifully
liver difficult want to get right not
only that but it's tempered and you
don't think of sort of um fried the
liver with North African cuisine however
the combination bab and the barley
cuscus works brilliantly well I've got
an issue with the liver however the lamb
is cooked perfectly and it's a loiner
lamb so it's it's been shown
respect authentic classic
untouched meat falling off the
bone
that's delicious I mean really delicious
lamb is just melting your mouth it needs
to be a little bit more trimmed excess
fat removed however sauce is incredible
you can see there's 30 years of
experience into that cuz it's just
packed full of flavor this is such an
amazing contrast and Momo's
interpretation as modern fresh fragrant
delivers a big punch uncertain about the
liver everything else it is delicious AO
is rich auth authentic and just steeped
with passion like him and right now it's
I'm stuck do I go forward with a
modernization of North African cuisine
or do I stay in the history of something
classically done it's too tight to
[Music]
call two fantastic North African
restaurants but only one can win a place
in the
semi-final
okay
right what I saw today was two
completely different dishes but
done with
pride history and Innovation
AO you stuck to your roots I think
you're back in Algeria yes chef and you
back with your mother and your your
grandma and you were you were there yes
chef I can identify the authenticity the
classic style and the richness of that
beautiful David it's very rare to find a
British Chef cooking out of his comfort
zone but tonight you came and you you
moved the goalpost you modernized North
African cuisine and it was done with
Flare which I didn't expect you to
do however this round is not one on a
single dish just think of the journey so
far in this competition go back to the
coachload of diners turning up all at
the same time the pressure of serving
all those guests in under 2 hours was a
nightmare then all of a sudden you can
let your hair down and let's get back to
cooking and then you've been secretly
filmed both restaurants came through
that test and they both had their highs
and they both had their
[Music]
lows
listening to the diners tasting both
dishes based on everything we've done in
this
competition the resturant going through
to the
semi-finals congratulations
too that's yes
[Music]
oh David don't stop that level of
pushing to the extreme well done thank
you sir well done thank you I'm good to
at the
moment I'm good to I've got a lot of
fight left in me give me a chance I I'll
do it again
congratulations yeah very very proud so
pleased cuz he you know it means such a
lot
I'm sorry to see Momo go David is a
brave and passionate Chef who is pushing
the boundaries of North African
cuisine but AO are a truly fabulous
restaurant and I can't wait to go back
there that's why they've gone through
right now this competition is only going
to get tougher and I hope they don't let
me
down Britain has some of the finest
restaurants in the world we were a con
Underdog for years but now we're at the
top of our game so who's the very best I
asked you where you love to eat out and
you sent me over 12, th000 nominations
for this competition but there can only
be one winner how do I find them by
choosing my two favorites every week and
testing them to the absolute Breaking
[Music]
Point who will crack under the
incredible pressure and who'll come
shining
[Music]
through my Nationwide rest competition
is entering the home straight so tonight
it's the last
Heat so far I found my best Italian
restaurant cmir from Bristol my top
Indian prashad from Bradford my favorite
Chinese you andu in
Blackburn for Tai n Jim from St Andrews
for British the milstone and Sheffield
flying the flag for French winterham
fields from
Lincolnshire and my best North African
restaurant Azo from West
London first it's do or die with the
last place in my semi-finals up for
grabs from your favorite Spanish
[Music]
restaurants over the last couple of
years has been a real growth in Spanish
cooking in the UK there's so much more
to it than just
Pella the Spanish are hugely proud of
the culinary Heritage but also great
innovators the best Spanish restaurants
combine tradition and modern techniques
to keep you coming back for
more I've handpicked two amazing Spanish
restaurants from hundreds of nominations
to battle it
[Music]
out from the heart of the capital it's
pheno the established pioneer of modern
Tapas in the UK are we the best Spanish
restaurant in
London there you go they're locking
horns with newcomer El parata dapas in
Notting Hill flying the flag for a whole
new generation of Spanish
cuisine we always go that extra mile not
just me me
[Music]
everybody I'm going to push both the
Spanish contenders to the very edge with
three incredible
challenges first it's every restaurant's
worst nightmare 30 ravenous customers
will arrive in order all at the same
[Music]
time stop number one is feno a sleek and
stylish tapest restaurant in central
London opened 7 years ago and it's owned
by two brothers Sam and Eddie now the
heart boys have really helped ch change
and transform our perception on Spanish
cooking they have the most amazing
female head chef downstairs who runs her
kitchen with such military position my
diners and I are in for one hell of a
treat good to see you how are you nice
to see you yes very well Gordon this is
n baragan Hi how are you and Alia and is
the team all female not all not all the
bosses are female yeah that's enough
right yeah that's enough and and the
rest of them are terrified I I can
imagine they don't put a finger out of
place yeah really surpris
surprise Brothers samon EDI have
restaurants in their blood raised around
their parents missing Star restaurant
and hotel we grew up from a pretty
tender age in restaurants the whole time
literally from the moment we could hold
a knife or pour wine at drinks parties
and hand round the olives in just 7
years the brothers have built their own
Empire of high-end London restaurants
renowned for their vibrant atmosphere
and fantastic
service F's got an amazing energy
consider about 90 people at once and
they're all having three to four tap hat
each you know it's something like 700
dishes coming out of the kitchen so
there's a great Buzz to the
room tough and talented headchef NZ has
been cooking Exquisite classic Tapas ofo
since it opened many of her dish is
inspired by her Basque
Roots I want crispy I want o for me the
most important thing is the
Taste no more than three ingredients
that's what I like in the plate that's
perfection we're actually quite a
traditional Spanish restaurant you know
we're not trying to break the mold what
we like to do is is just Source the best
ingredients we can and cook them simply
so the secret is just to let that duck
egg yolk
ooze it's delicious I mean who would
have thought that peas and broad beans
could be so exciting that's one portion
well I suppose it's one Tap House
portion that's shared isn't it I I
wouldn't share that with anybody
no this woman is truly gifted thank you
could her incredible passion take feno
all the way in this competition
my din is going to be arriving just
under 5 minutes from now NE I can feel
that adrenaline yeah from here I can see
it pulsating through those veins you can
probably do this standing on your head
alone with no one in the kitchen however
yeah just just do what you do best and
good luck thank
you they're going to need it cuz in just
a few minutes we've got company my 30
Discerning diners will arrive an order
on mass so far every restaurant in the
competition has struggled with this
Challenge and I fear even a slick
operation like feno is going to feel the
[Music]
heat okay guys in 1 minute okay the
customers they're coming in 1 minute
yeah
[Music]
yes hi there hi
there I want you to start to cut bread
please the customers they here NE has
his Poise for Action like a caged
tiger would' like to talk you through
the menu and explain what we got on this
evening actually tur fantastic um in the
dining room prors of charm salmon edti
are already breaking the ice we've got a
poach duck egg um with fresh peas broad
beans hamon and some fresh mint the
cette flowers are stuffed with goat
cheese with a little bit of thyme and
shalots and they're dipped in tempora
and deep fried the brothers are clearly
just as passionate about tonight's menu
as their head chef
I need chewing total yeah okay I need
chewing
total n's Basque roots are coming
through loud and clear in the simple but
Exquisite seasonal Delicacies of a
quality rarely found outside
Spain very much this is really nice wow
they look good the presentation looks
fantastic this is delicious absolutely
fantastic one of the best dishes I've
actually ever had just over 45 minutes
gone and this place is absolutely
rocking customers loving the food great
atmosphere in there but right over there
on that hot plate that's where the real
Spanish fire is because she is over
everything every plate is
immaculate okay guys I need yeah one
more you Olia one now okay one
now Nas is seasoning every dish tasting
every sauce Olia two much olive oil in
there okay very tiny very tiny very tiny
only one like a true artist she has
complete Command over every plate don't
don't this woman is a culinary Picasso
okay start to play the potatoes now yeah
yes okay one turbo two s p one BR V is
table 14
yes this is the best part of the or the
cooking okay does she normally do
everything like this no one's allowed to
touch anything but her
just pass everything to her and she does
everything yes yes yes okay one addition
please yes she's a control fore she's
worse than me every night she's like
this yeah yeah she's really fascinating
about you know really really really
fascina I can't fault n's dedication but
I can see a problem she's sending out
dishes as soon as they're ready rather
than ensuring everyone on the table is
fed together we were going to have uh
two starters between the for so we
wanted them both to arrive at the same
time we could get um stuck in doesn't
seem to be arriving in
present where's the
squid have we ask kitchen I know because
no no no no we have to ask Eddie's on it
but I've clocked another lady waiting
for her
turbet was that last uh make the five
ladies this sort of issue could ruin a
whole table's dining experience and Sam
knows it is there a last course on Table
9 coming I think that they should serve
all the food together and I didn't want
my friend's food getting cold while I
was waiting for mine so a little bit
mythed I need one
more now one don't make
Meo Nas is determined not to let a
little slip up like this ruin her
service within minutes two hot dishes
are winging their way out to the dining
room T 21
okay
let's go sorry about that Madam thank
you very much and just to make sure
there's no hard feelings Sam is on the
charm offensive do you want me to show
you how you fill it the T you do know
your way around more or less I'm very
happy to do it some people like to
fiddle around and do it themselves other
prefer it thank you nicely done
excellent It's meaty but it's a very
light flavor there's a lot of vinegar
and olive oil that they put with it as
they do in Spain um and it but it
doesn't overpower the fish really really
lovely second course star Waring pck
yeah yes all the star is gone yes yes
yes we're doing second course now and in
the pl I want to see 1 2 3 4 5 6 7even
eight tarot okay eight tarot as well as
the delicious
turbet for the main course NZ is serving
a specialty roast suckling pig math
wateringly sweet and tender it smells
[__]
amazing it's another Spanish show
stopper the sucking pig is fantastic
full of flavor really well cooked the
simple potatoes that it it comes on
Exquisite delicious the whole thing just
melts in your mouth and more important
it's got a really nice fragrant sort of
well time baile and
rosem this could well be the best food
I've seen so far in this competition the
longer I'm here the more exciting I'm
get how many more main call you've got
to go that's it that's it yeah all gone
all gone
[Music]
service is almost
over but with a combination of delicious
desserts and samon Edd's unfaltering
charm the dining room is still buzzing
our mother um grew up in my Yorker but
she's actually half Scottish half
Bulgarian so we sort of look Spanish but
aren't at all the fish was beautifully
cooked I had a tur but I I couldn't
fault it it was beautiful the food was
fantastic today absolutely brilliant
delivered on flavor and very very
impressed thank you very much goodbye
thank you very much thank you thanks
thanks for
coming right um okay what can I pick on
what can I say that we have to improve
on here there's a moment in service
tonight service gets awkward and that
was just after the star had
gone that's the only Awkward Moment I
Saw the food's
amazing you can smile now yeah yeah no
no no you don't do it often but you can
now yes
the service tonight you two just raised
the bar good job take it
toas another Pig
Tres next has feno's Challenger pushed
it too far with her experimental menu
are you can have no wa not for me and
will my secret Diner make n's loser cool
there's a hair in the salads D oh
no
in my quest to find the best restaurant
in Britain my posy of hungry diners are
riding into town about to roll up at the
second Spanish Contender fighting for
the last place in the
semi-final the pioneering Al parata Deus
or the pirate in London's hip noting
Hill is managed by Roberto and the
kitchen run by Madrid boy
Omar it's only been open for 2 years
already it's got rave reviews this young
Spanish Chef he's only 26 and this guy
really does have
talent hola how are you very well and
yourself good to see you're very well
indeed thank you I'm so happy to be here
small
restaurant small kitchen big passion big
passion show that on every plate of
course
well HF Omar has a hugely impressive CV
having worked for the celebrated
molecular gastronome Baron edrian of elb
in Spain voted one of the best
restaurants in the world it was a
tremendous experience for me that has
influenced the rest of my cooking and
the rest of my
career this young Pretender has an Ultra
Modern approach to tapers and uses
molecular cooking techniques to take
Spanish cuisine into the 21st century
with huge
style I like beautiful things in life as
we all do so I think it is great when
you are sitting down in your table and
something beautiful comes into it even
though you don't unexpected Omar's
experimental methods can turn a
traditional dish on its head like his
jellied
gaspacho it's very clever cuz you got
this nice chilled jelly tasting exactly
the same but a completely different
texture yeah in his mission to stand out
Omar bravely Embrace his daring
ingredients like his ComEd Cox comb the
crest that comes from the head of the
cockroll which most British butchers
throw away they actually give it to us
for free all the time cuz no one's
ordering them no I don't think there's
many chefs anywhere in the country that
have has threee ingredients that can be
clever enough to charge money for it
smart
ass this competition has just gone up a
notch on the back of the Antonio vas are
cooking little bastard far too goodl
looking to be a
chef he has passion guts and a huge pair
of kohas service
Omar will need balls of steel
tonight he's got just 2 hours to serve
all 30 of my Discerning
diners and stake his claim to be the
most avanguard Spanish Chef in
Britain okay just under 5 minutes my
dinos will were here 30 of them those
you CED me earlier were like little sort
of miniature works of art so make sure
my D have the exact same experience good
luck let's do it thank
[Music]
you we will put all our effort all our
knowledge all our commitment to make
this happen I really want to win
this Omar's definitely not playing it
safe with the pig Str of capaco and his
cockc longest Ste molosso a type of
Spanish risoto I've got this image of
this chicken's head just been ripped is
that what you ordered basically it cost
CL is just the top of the of the C they
really T like really really amazing with
some able guidance from manager Roberto
the averly avanguard menu is creating
quite a
[Music]
stir wait not for
me you can have it I'm going to give it
a try no point not okay
first
check with all 30 orders taken can this
young Buccaneer seize this enormous
Challenge and Lead his crew to a
resounding
success two migas another
[Music]
Pig
service this is complex food and a lot
could go wrong but so far Omar's call as
a cucumber in his
gaspacho this place are Immaculate I
mean we've just started service and
we're only half an hour into it but
composed yeah bloody good service but
the food looking absolutely spotless but
will his unorthodox dishes be too
experimental for my Diner's
taste really good the Cao Pig strotter
yeah it's amazing the texture takes a
bit of getting used to but the flavors
are incredible I never thought I'd say
i' eat a
pig customers are loving the food and
it's not exactly what they expected
listen the atmosphere you know anyone
would think there's music playing in the
background the music are the customers
they're
[Music]
happy even the coxco mosso is going down
well but each dish must be made to order
and he's putting pressure on the kitchen
[Music]
rice is popular tonight no yeah it's
selling quite a lot and the coom I think
challenge the customer sometimes so well
it's a rare ingredient they very ready
see the kitchen sends out the last Cox
con
moso that's edible right it is yeah
excellent really suckling really tasty
and really nice yeah fored that's nicer
than I ever imagined it to be yeah
fantastic but Roberto fails to notice
the happy Diner's neighbor has yet to be
fed I think it's just been a a small mix
up my my main course hasn't arrived yet
customer's happy very happy yeah how
many tables you got left to go uh
desserts no more hot food no more H Food
[Music]
really finally Roberto spots the
problem oh [__]
there's no way Omar can get this out
[Music]
quickly bit of
but everyone's already finished
their sorry
M what happened I did a
mistake because of the rushing
everything came at once but yeah the
most important thing is to do the the
food correctly even though they need to
wait a couple of minutes extra it's
fine it's not until dessert start to
leave the kitchen that the delayed
molosso is
sent chew just
swall was it worth the
wait abely worth the way but just a
shame it took um or you guys all
finished yours but that's let down it
does the food
fantastic El parata's near faultless
performance has been down to Omar's
sheer skill and passion he's pulled off
the remarkable making humble and
unappealing ingredients tastes like a
million
dollars it's detail it's a piece of art
on the plate it looks beautiful it
tastes beautiful I think the food here
is absolutely incredible some things
that I never would have thought of
eating but actually worked really really
well
tough
challenge my diners are over the moon
well done thankk wait for the final yes
yeah you're already there are you we are
yes yeah I love that confidence
someone's like you've won the World Cup
good job
[Music]
excellent both feno and El parata
thrived in my coach trip they performed
quite brilliantly now I've invited them
both to come and see me to review their
performances at least that's what I've
told them what neither team realizes is
that they've already faced my second
very revealing
test I asked my secret diners to visit
their restaurants I've seen exactly what
each restaurant is like when they're not
in the
spotlight first I deployed Sarah Duran
Robertson a top food consultant armed
with secret recording equipment she
never shks in a mission to be a tricky
customer
could I swap two of those could I have
the prawns instead and the borck she
scrutinized established heavyweight
feno hi guys how how you good to see
good to see you that was a big test but
unknown to yourselves after I visited I
sent in a secret
Diner this is what they saw you ready my
heart is beating your heart is
beating
what have I touched something hello I've
touched something I don't know what it
is my hand's covered in oil oh my God I
don't know EXC no that's okay I don't
know where it's come
from oh it's the side of the table don't
worry it's just all here it's got all
oil on it so I can
see it's not brilliant my first
experience in the restaurant they tied
it up very quickly but as she was doing
it I know noticed that my glass isn't
clean either so I'm also sending that
back that's not very
good it looks pretty oh yes thank you
actually I know I've started
badly it's not great there was O on the
table glass was dirty but she could not
have handled it
better thank you very much bad start
dirty table not a good start dealt with
amazingly bang just like
that if we were to have Sher we would
say a Mana or Fino or a Monti what's the
difference well the between Mania Ando
there is not much difference it's just
the at the Village they are very close
so all of them they have this saltiness
flavor we have one we they only sell it
for two months a year which is this one
would it be possible maybe to try a
little bit would you like to try this
one yes please I'm one of the man one of
the man yes yes I'm thank you I've been
to her which is the Sher capital of
Spain gone through all the classes all
the tastings but she actually managed to
explain it very well in about three
sentences and kind of why didn't I just
come here and speak to her I would have
had a Sher master class in seconds so
nice to get that level of excitement and
amazing insight and very knowledgeable
nice
touch oh thank
you
thank
you what he was to slap Dash sloped on
the table looked at himself in the
mirror didn't look at at the
table oh wow okay so
potato um I think yeah I don't think we
ordered that thank
you now trying to give my razor clams to
the wrong table he doesn't have a clue I
wouldn't have him out here at all
my God and it's not even my restaurant
but it pains
me of course we don't want that to
happen definitely not anyone who comes
into contact with with with the
customers needs to know what they know
what they're talking about
engaged next Sarah's going to play one
of the dirtiest tricks in the secret
Diner
book oh
no putting one of her own hairs in the
food I was so so so excuse me
PE there's a hair in this
salad I just wondered if I could swap it
thank
you no that's okay thank you they' that
really well the waitress like taken it
away she showed it to the manager who
had a good look at it they looked at
each other up PA and she's taking it
straight back to the
kitchen I don't know where it's from
it's not from the kitchen for sure
because they don't have a show hair so I
don't know anyway I told that have to
make another one making another one
thank you very much thank
you apologetic bang stad away customer
at ease dealt with brilliantly you know
what it was a great step there's a table
Del thing things started to happen the
food was fantastic the waitress was
absolutely amazing hand fact that was
very waiter he's a big let down he
doesn't know what he's doing lots of
mistakes he's all over the place and
that's a shame because everything else
is what' you make of that Anna who's
looking after them did a great job but I
think sort of seeing the junior guy not
up to speed is something that we can do
something about and you know something
that we we ought to improve on
definitely tough test we're only human
and we need make mistakes clearly but
how you handle
them you know we've got a couple of
things to you know to take away and work
on of course we're disappointed it
wasn't 100% perfect but I think most of
the team really do know what they're
doing and and you know it's a reasonably
easy job for us to make sure that they
all do you know it's a good challenge
for us over the next few weeks our next
uh challenge is going to be tough and we
must to send everything perfect so I
want to win noway and I will love to win
and I hope we
win next my undercover spy gets the cold
shoulder from El parata that's
Facebook on the computer checking out
his mates and
still my secret diners without the
[Music]
wine renowned Spanish restaurant feno
okay still at eight it's locking horns
with young Pretenders El parata to tap
us b b bamos
they're fighting for the last remaining
place in my
semi-finals El parata's 26-year-old head
chef Omar suf Adrian and front of house
manager Ricardo put in a hugely
impressive performance in my first test
but they're about to find out I've been
spying on them hi guys hi and thank you
so much for
coming I have something to tell you
you've been tested twice because after I
left
I then sent in my secret diners to make
sure it wasn't a freak
[Laughter]
night and this is what
happened Al here we
go professional snooper Simon Davis
makes his living spotting faults with
restaurants food and service I told him
not to hold back when he visited El
parata
M it's lovely actually that cheese that
Bon cheese is
really gets in your mouth and then just
keeps going just keeps keeps delivering
now this will be a real Telltale sign
this is octopus with Paprika on and then
Capers very very very good that's one of
the best
dishes I've had for some time
actually they know what they're
doing
loves the
food some of the most exciting food he's
ever
eaten but what about the
service the way to put the food
down about 11 minutes ago he hasn't come
back at
all not once to either see how we're
getting on engage Us in conversation it
tells me he doesn't really
care he just walked by again didn't say
anything to us I'm not feeling hugely
welcome here at a customer at the moment
that may very well be cuz he doesn't
like the cut of my gym but I've been
looking around the other tables and no
one's really getting particularly good
service good food is nothing without
great service they go hand in
glove what have we got here I think
that's Cod that's interesting isn't it
because they're not
olives they're raisins there's no
Peppers um there's no capers it's a
tre's description this year it says it
says it's with capers and olives but I
see a small amount of sultanas I we we
didn't changed the menu as you've
changed the dish yeah but it's the old
dish on here yeah I'm allergic to
those I can't eat sultanas do you want
me to take away the on the plate or just
no I can't it's been on if it's been on
the plate I can't I can't have it yeah
we were keen on that one
you can't just offer to take the Salas
off and bring back the plagues also very
mind now we've been chatting and looking
at it and stuff it's cold
now Cod on the menu so with the Capers
and peppers arrives with raisins what
happened there my fa Notting the menu
not changing the menu just uh yeah I
mean how
uninterested was that waiter he's like a
zombie yeah I feel quite a shame when
I've seen this sort of attitude in the
service guys have got a cool hip amazing
restaurant there you're sat on something
potentially
brilliant and if someone wants to turn
up to work and talk like that to
customers getting washing [__]
dishes I was going to get a glass of
glass of red
wine which would you
advise on very nice no I'm going to have
this one the REM y thank you just a
glass see where's my where's my glass of
of red
wine that's
Facebook on the
computer checking out his mates and
still my secret Diner is without the
wine excuse me
um your IE ordered a glass of red wine
oh Sor
yeah all right sry I I hope I didn't
interrupt you no
okay
[Music]
unbelievable what kind of impression
does that serve to customers when a
waiter sat there on a
computer I think it just over 40 with
ahead for the quality of the food and
the ability of the
chef it's good value where it suddenly
stops being good value is when you have
service like the service that we've seen
today it is such a shame to see
fantastic food let down by extremely
poor service all the the hard work and
especially these guys putting in the
kitchen going just down the drain by bad
attitude and just horrify you've got
every right to feel let down but it's
not over and done with it's still very
strong in this competition and you need
to bounce
back lot to
do there was no wrong with the food was
a wrong with the service so I I feel
personally responsible for that so yeah
I just feel you know that we fail
disappointed so we need to work together
as a team and we will make sure this
doesn't happen ever
again both restaurants have been tested
to their limits but things are only
going to get
tougher I'm taking the chefs out of
their kitchens and pitting them against
each other in my Flagship
restaurant good I've challenged each
Chef to create one amazing dish for 20
guests really really one of the biggest
day for me in my career if we go forward
now it's going to be just a dream you
know come
true it really means a lot for a chef to
be here I hope I can deliver on quality
as this restaurant deserve let's do it
yeah but win them the last remaining
place in the semi-finals it will have to
be the finest dish of their
lives big test 20 guests only one
stunning dish make sure that every ounce
of passion excitement knowledge and
experience goes into that plate and at
the end of it one restaurant is going
through the semi-final one is leaving
the competition off we
[Music]
go both restaurants will be going all
out to win with a classic Spanish
ingredient pork favored for its amazing
versatility pork's a very tough me to
get right and when it's overcooked
nothing worse
dry outside a dining room full of VIPs
all with a passion for Spanish food will
help me judge both thises tonight
including renowned Spanish Samilia Bruno
Marano and the Spanish Ambassador Don
cares cahuana eplet all the front of
house teams can do is wait and
hope an order Al four covers table five
four Pig cheeks yes Che thank
you after my secret Diner bombshell Omar
is putting everything on the line
tonight with an incredibly complex
dish he's mixing the refined with The
Rustic a rich Pig's Trotter fagra and
hamon Wellington served with a sweet
fake puree will sit alongside some of
the cheapest cuts of the pig slow bra
tongue and
cheeks they are the ugly cats of the POG
you need to be very skillful to make the
best out of them but uh yeah very
confident I've tasted all the food I'm
very happy with the flavors the
combination of them all together so
hopefully they all like
it so you really are going all out there
there's a lot going on there a lot of
going on the combination I think it
fantastic in the
mouth seriously ambitious I mean there's
like three dishes on that one plate he's
obsessed with being so quirky I just
hope the sort of balance of that dish
comes in together and it's not too
weighted on order four cover t five feno
for po cutlets yes yes come on guys
please at least give me an answer look
it's not it's not
compling H in her own kitchen Nas is a
control freak shouting orders left right
and center but today she's like a
different person I want to hear that
communication and a little bit of O
please I hope her silence doesn't mean
she's lost her nerve unorder four covers
table one f four pork cutlets yes yes
good now it's sounding like a
professional kitchen let's go
yeah today neas is sticking to a basque
Roots creating a simple dish packed with
authentic
flavors pork cutlets marinated in sweet
paprika accompanied by a silky smooth
cauliflower puree and broad beans cooked
with haml so your plain in strength
you're keeping it exactly what you cook
like in feno simple fun that's what I do
four simple things on the plate but
tasting amazing together that's what I
hope yeah for is lovely good I hope you
got the right one thank you thank you
with Foo I'm expecting magic she's kept
it simple it has to be perfect every
element on there four cutlets away how
long give me a Titan uh I'm ready
good now that looks fantastic love the
colors H vibrant shouting summer okay
look again
beautiful absolutely fantastic you happy
with those table two please go keep me
go guys yeah food's looking
amazing it's incredible they're just so
focused and getting their dishes
absolutely spot on so focused I mean
that's the most focused I've seen any
chef in this
competition NZ is lavishing her complete
attention on each dish letting the
ingredients speak for
themselves NZ yes sir two pork away last
table please yes fantastic go Oliver
happy yes please
go please table four thank you very nice
well done good job table
two but will my diners be wowed or
underwhelmed by the Simplicity of her
dish colors nice combination very very
nice
flavor how long for the first table
please 3 minutes 3 minutes yes sir
great Omar and Adriana are attempting to
elevate the cheapest cuts of pork up to
my Michelin standards can they really
make a silk purse out of a s's ear when
we come to the hot plight come together
so you got a bit of you know teamwork
going on there yeah I don't want that
food hanging around here too long when
it's cooked like that I want it out yes
to make sure all five elements reach the
table piping hot and beautifully
suculent they must pull together I asked
second time to come and help him so he
can four place that's all work as a team
want to get involved yeah okay just
about perfection that's all come on you
got to wipe all these little plages I've
got the ambassador of Spain out there
guys yeah I want everything done and
that's the tongue there yeah yes the
tongue he's managed to impress my diners
with his challenging ingredients once
but can Omar pull it off again good go
please table one thank you service
[Music]
please the flavor the textures actually
had never tried the dunk before quite
surprised really really
nice service is over okay good well done
water
what before I taste both dishes I'm Keen
to find out what my guests thought of
them starting with Al parata let's talk
pork the Wellington the pork TRS and the
yes yes that was extraordinary both are
very good but El Pata is been more
creative in texture in
flavor I've never had time before it
abely delicious I love Pig totters but I
thought the sort of little rrap could
have done with a bit more pigs chter and
a bit less pastry but you know delicious
you know picking at
straws will elata be so generous about
foo's dish good evening nice to see you
talk to about the pork chop yeah it was
great uh I really enjoy it the
combination and flavors was great I
think it was just understanding dish it
was really really good the Alo dish was
a very simple dish done very very well
beautiful I prefer the Fino dish I think
it's more simple but at the end it was
better for me the other one it was too
much tonight I've witnessed some of the
most outstanding food in the competition
from two remarkable
chefs we've tried our best we' put a lot
of passion and knowledge into our
preparation and service went to smooth
so I'm very happy very pleased
I'm happy with my this we love to win
yeah now I have the impossible task of
choosing which of these two will go
through to my
[Music]
semi-finals my two Spanish contenders
feno and El parata dapas have both
attained near Perfection at my Flagship
Resturant
tonight my diners were blown away by
some of the best foods seen in the
competition
now I face a truly difficult decision
which of these Spanish restaurants do I
believe represents the future of Spanish
cooking before I choose I need to taste
the food cooked here
tonight both this you look amazing I
mean really vibrant and just ooze
Perfection fenos marinated pork chop
four things on the
plate delicious I mean really good got
that nice spicy authentic Spanish taste
for a pork chop it's fabulous cow puree
a little bit grainy but the combination
of the resting juices and that chicken
stock across the broad beans really
delicious to get four ingredients on a
plate tasting that amazing that's a very
confident clever
cook Al looks amazing start off with the
pork cheek and the
tongue that is phenomenal just melt in
your mouth one criticism the Fig puree
very very sweet a little bit too much
the Wellington is got that robust rustic
flavor to the dish delicious it's the
cheapest cuts and they've made it taste
like the most
[Music]
expensive two incredible Spanish
restaurants but only one can go through
to the
semi-final
okay okay first off well done an amazing
job from both restaurants I invited you
here today to
really create something that is off the
charts now there's you play to your
strength four things on the plate very
bold the pork was stunning cooked
beautifully Hammer broad beans it was
delicious
what could I criticize there you make a
cauliflower puree I found it a slight
touch too
grainy Omar I asked for fireworks you
create an explosion I asked you to use
pork and the only thing you didn't use
were the toenails of the Trotter pork
cheek beautifully braced tongue Brave
and then you do a Wellington Pig Trotter
wrapped in pastry I've never seen that
how could to criticize that dish the
pure is very sweet you put sweet and
Rich together it needs acidity just
something to bang to lift and separate
that I put the two dishes together and
looked at them I thought jeez where didd
you start there was a fraction in it
it's been an amazing journey and it's
been packed with highs and
lows the
winner of the Spanish
category for me is the restaurant that I
want to
revisit is it for the fireworks from a
parata or is it the warmth and the skill
from
feno the closest fought
contest the restaurant going through to
the
semi-final based on everything I've
experienced seen
tasted
is
feno
congratulations absolutely amazing
amazing amazing amazing simplicity at
its best wonderful congratulations
really well done good
job Omar we haven't seen the last of you
you have the most amazing excitement
with your level of creativity well done
thank you it's a shame you know a good
restaurant needs to be consistently good
and we haven't in a way but uh yeah we
will get it
right it's a great thing for for the
team for the restaurant for me
especially for me
is kind can't even speak is it's
unbelievable what an extraordinary day
so sorry to see alata leave the
competition but so happy for feno to get
to the semi-finals and now the real
battle
begins